I did finally see the movie last night
at our red carpet Premiere it was my
first time seeing it as I think I've
already complained about that they
wouldn't let me see it ahead of time in
fact most of the scenes in the film I I
wasn't even there when it was filming
because I'm only my characters only
shows up a few times here and there so I
went into this almost like any other
member of the audience and I also except
that I went into it ready to rip it
apart in my mind and be hypercritical
because you know that's how I am with
any creative project that I'm involved
in but I'm happy to report that it is um
the movie is very funny it works as a a
satire of gender ideology but it also
stands on its own as a as a comedy and
that was one of the things I was
watching for it's like yeah it makes the
point makes the point very effectively
so we want to do that you want to make
the point uh satirically which the film
does but aside from the message aside
from the point does it just is it just
funny on its own and uh I'm happy to say
that it certainly is